[Music]
hi I'm Mark H with the Alabama
Cooperative Extension system and with me
today is Chad Norris director of the
Tennessee Valley research and Extension
Center here in Limestone County Alabama
Chad tell we have worked with uh
harvesting water for irrigation for
several years on the station uh what's
the concept of harvesting water for
irrigation here in the Tennessee Valley
Mark as you know most of the Iration
systems pull from streams it's extremely
difficult to obtain well water although
there are some wells but the majority of
them pull from streams so there's a
tremendous Demand on these small streams
during drought times when we really need
the irrigation water so the idea came
about here at the center 18 years ago
for us to have a water harvesting and
storage project so what we do we have
limestone Creek a leg of limestone Creek
that runs through the center so if
you're in high water water times which
is typically November through March
stream is in full pool there's a lot of
water and it's running down to the
Tennessee River at that time we'll pump
water from Limestone creb into a
reservoir that we have that contains 140
acre feet and we'll fill that Reservoir
and then strictly use that stored water
for our irrigation needs during the
growing season so it gives you water in
wet times to use in dry times what type
farming operation might this fit with
Chad it fits well with us of course we
uh B small LR compared to through larger
Growers uh I see some instances where
Mak some Growers of some specialty crops
which would be smaller Acres perhaps
could utilize this type of system and I
also understand there's some towns
municipalities that have considered
using this type of stor water system for
backup Water Supplies perhaps those typ
thank you chip appreciate your
information on harvesting water for all
of our irrigation videos and other AD
videos visit our website on YouTube
here's the address for that website
thank you for watching our video today
if we can help you please let us know